uh well look it wasn't no the short
answer is no I don't regret asking David
to be lieutenant governor when i ran i
think david has been thrust into a very
difficult environment and if you look at
jon corzine in New Jersey who was a
remarkably talented capable individual
he was voted out of office he tried to
do many things that were there were wise
Arnold Schwarzenegger different side of
the political aisle he his approval
rating is down in the 30s Ted Strickland
in Ohio deval Patrick in Massachusetts
being a governor right now is a very
difficult job revenues are way down
people still want to get their education
funding they still want Medicaid and
healthcare to be funded and when you
have shrinking revenues it's just a very
difficult environment to survive
politically so david has been struggling
with that and I think the budgetary
proposals he is his put forth are quite
wise and but unpopular and that's the
nature of being a governor at certain
points in time do I disagree with his
choice of kirsten gillibrand yes I I
think she has unfortunately shown that
she's more a careerist than politician
dedicated to standing up for a principle
on issues of immigration rights on
issues of gun control and unissued
relating to some core principles that I
believe in but i will say she she is the
senator and we'll see what happens
you